[Música]
[Aplausos]
y eso mi papá en un accidente de carro
fue una muerte instantánea casi recuerdo
haber sido yo quien contestó la llamada
del hospital avisándonos que él estaba
ahí fue fue una muerte inesperada algo
que jamás veíamos venir
pero que sin duda llegó a cambiar toda
absolutamente toda mi vida en un minuto
y a raíz de este suceso fue cuando
realmente llegué a valorar el trabajo de
mi mamá mi mamá siempre ha trabajado en
una empresa
en un empleo que le ha llegado a
permitir tener esta flexibilidad para
poder combinar su rol de vida de mamá y
trabajo yo yo crítico en este ejemplo en
casa y para mí siempre fue algo muy
normal y natural que ella trabajara
pero en el momento que el papá llega a
fallecer gracias al trabajo de mi mamá
la estabilidad económica de mi familia
no se vio afectada nuestro estilo de
vida no cambió realmente no sé qué
hubiera pasado si la realidad hubiera
sido otra
pero ahí fue cuando comprendí la
importancia de su trabajo y el impacto
que éste llegó a tener
hoy les vengo a platicar acerca de la
importancia del rol de la mujer en el
trabajo en el mundo laboral
cada vez más mujeres estamos en la
economía del mundo y formamos parte de
ella y cada vez más mujeres toman
posiciones de liderazgo sin embargo el
número aún no es suficiente
la brecha de género no se ha disminuido
en los últimos diez años
y para lograr esta equidad de género al
menos en nuestro núcleo en mi opinión
deben de pasar estas tres cosas la
primera como mujeres y como mujer llegar
a creer en ti llegar a creer que es
posible seguir tus sueños que te puede
realizar en muchos roles y no estar
únicamente condicionadas a uno que puede
ser y hacer lo que tú quieras busquemos
un trabajo que nos motive y nos apasione
y también entre mujeres busquemos y
seamos ese apoyo porque podemos llegar a
ser las peores enemigas escucha y pon
atención a que cuento te cuentas a ti
misma es necesario empezar a cambiar esa
historia que te dices y también
actualizar tus creencias porque tus
creencias son las primeras en bloquear
tu crecimiento
el segundo el segundo punto eliminar el
machismo es increíble como hoy en día
aún despiden a mujeres por estar
embarazadas hace poquito un vídeo que se
hizo muy viral de una chava que grabó su
despido por estar embarazada y en la
conversación del jefe éste le dijo
million cosas horribles pero mi opinión
la peor fue a nosotros así no no nos
sirve
ya no sirve porque está embarazada
wow y esto lo peor del caso es que
sucede muchísimo más de lo que nos
podemos imaginar
yo creo que hasta que la incapacidad por
maternidad y paternidad sea igual y
desde la ley vamos a lograr esta equidad
hasta que el hombre llegue a tomar un
rol activo en casa en el cuidado de los
hijos y lo asuma también como su
responsabilidad esta conversación va a
ser muy distinta hay que buscar a la
pareja que sea una pareja realmente en
donde ambos se puedan realizar y hombres
dejen atrás sus creencias machistas
porque en este siglo ya no tienen
espacio en el tercer y último punto
llegar a flexibilizar la cultura de
trabajo en la cultura laboral que
venimos arrastrando desde la era
industrial nueva que había para formar
una familia con roles equitativos
debemos de flexibilizar esta cultura
para que ambos tanto hombres como
mujeres puedan tener un rol activo en
casa y en el trabajo hoy en día seis de
cada diez mujeres dejan de trabajar
cuando tienen a su primer hijo y cuando
tienen un segundo aumenta a ocho de cada
diez y esto es muy obvio porque no
existen sistemas de soporte que retengan
a la mujer en la etapa de maternidad en
el trabajo
las empresas necesitan evolucionar y
adaptarse a la era digital y adoptar
esas tendencias laborales como es el
trabajo flexible porque si no realmente
no van a sobrevivir se sorprenderían de
los beneficios que esta flexibilidad
viene implementada conlleva a una
organización
a raíz de mi historia y de estos tres
puntos fue como nace mi empresa de bolsa
rosa para implementar la cultura de
trabajo flexible en las organizaciones y
para integrar y reintegrar a las mujeres
a la fuerza laboral en puestos con
esquemas de trabajo flexibles hemos
comprobado una y otra vez que cada vez
que vinculamos a una mujer a una mamá en
un puesto flexible como el compromiso y
la productividad se llega a permear y a
florecer y esto yo lo vivo con un equipo
de trabajo y día con día la mayoría son
mamás pero aunque no lo sean el hecho de
tener el control de tu tiempo trabajar
desde casa y por objetivos el resultado
para la empresa es inigualable y aunque
únicamente nos veamos una vez al mes el
sentido de pertenencia no se pierde sino
por el contrario aumenta
y cabe mencionar que ha mencionado
también que yo empecé esta empresa
porque como buena milenio no me adapte
al mundo corporativo y cuando detecte y
encontré esta oportunidad y necesidad en
el mercado me apasione de esta idea la
hice mía y emprendí este proyecto
yo creo en la en la libertad de elegir
de ser y de hacer de cada persona en el
amor en la felicidad y en la plenitud
que puede llegar a alcanzar cualquiera
mientras tenga las herramientas y
condiciones necesarias para poder llegar
a alcanzar esta plenitud
agradezco a dios por darme la
oportunidad de llegar a esta plenitud
como mujer esposa emprendedora y ahora
como mamá
gracias por escucharme los dejo con este
vídeo de bolsa rosa que va por ti y las
siguientes generaciones
gracias
[Música]
soy coordinadora de iconos y marketing
digital
soy la jefa de relaciones públicas soy
especialista en financiamiento
corporativo soy gerente de planeación
soy directora de centro de vinculación
tecnológica
y si también soy mamá
soy la que prepara el desayuno de dios
y resuelve los problemas de tu empresa
de perro
soy la que se sabe las mejores canciones
de cuna
y la que sabe las mejores estrategias
para cerrar negocios
sola que organiza los pendientes de mi
casa y la que sabe organizar los mejores
equipos de trabajo soy la que no se
pierde un festival de su hijo pero
siempre está lista para la presentación
anual de resultados porque creo en mi
familia pero también creo en mi propio
valor pero en un mundo donde no tengo
que elegir con el balance es posible
creo que no solo soy mamá soy mucho más
creo en mi futuro creo en el futuro de
tu empresa creo en nosotros
[Aplausos]